the budding space tourism industry has a
big year ahead
with more and more people mostly the
ultra wealthy booking their flights
but there's a lingering question on some
minds
how bad will space tourism be for our
climate
first things first bloomberg reporter
edward ludlow is here to explain what is
space tourism in the last couple of
years it's basically been taken to mean
civilian
space flight for recreational purposes
going into space whether it's for a few
minutes or for a longer period of time
just for the sheer experience of being
outside of earth's atmosphere for a few
minutes of weightlessness or a few days
of the experience
so blue origin and virgin galactic are
offering rides to sub-orbital space with
some customers paying up to 450 000 per
ticket a hefty price for a trip that
only achieves a few minutes of
weightlessness
even though suborbital flight barely
touches the edge of space will the
emissions from the uptick of space
tourism affect our atmosphere karen
rosenloff who has been working on
stratospheric ozone research for the
last 30 years tells us right now there
is no clear answer the perturbation due
to rockets right now is not huge so in
i'm not sure that we could even tell you
outside of the uncertainties of our our
model estimates whether the current load
um from rockets has made a significant
climate impact i think what we can say
is you know we've seen variations in
things like black carbon over the last
20 years that we're actually
investigating to see is this consistent
with increases in rocket traffic
according to rosinloft these emissions
don't last in our middle atmosphere
forever when you put something up of the
middle atmosphere would you flush it in
about four years you know so if you
stopped emitting stuff
four years later
in terms of these kind of particles they
would mostly be done
part of the reason why it's difficult to
calculate the climate impact from human
space flight is that the rockets use a
range of different propulsion systems
and each produce different levels of
emissions we discuss blue origin
which uses a mixture of hydrogen and
oxygen as its propellant there's no
carbon being burned so there's very
little carbon by product from the
overall system then we talk about spacex
right spacex is the most active of the
launchers right now and it uses kerosene
good old-fashioned kerosene but it's
combustion and the by-product is large
volumes of of co2 virgin galactic uses
what's called a hybrid engine it does
use a propellant and an oxidizer but it
only does very short bursts so as we
discussed it's only a 60-second burn on
the rockets but the carbon that it puts
out is equivalent to an entire
trans-atlantic flight so there's two
ways of looking at it the actual space
mission itself the few minutes of
weightlessness does not have a high
carbon output relative to daily airline
travel but if they ramp up their number
of launches to say 400 a year of course
the impact will be much greater but
emissions from spacecrafts aren't the
only way our environment could be
impacted thiago suarez a systems
engineer at the european space agency
says that it's not just the burning of
the propellant that can impact our
environment but the actual production of
it we have
looked for example as the way we produce
the propellants because there's a big
massive propellant and if you do it in a
environmentally friendly way
[Music]
it can reduce significantly the
environmental impact but for satellites
i can tell you for example we are trying
to
recycle
germanium that is a very rare metal that
is used in
solar panels and in solar cells and this
is one of the major environmental
impacts that
we found out and that could indeed make
a big difference if we managed to find
ways to
recycle it scientists who study
atmospheric pollution also say
satellites launched into space might
have a larger impact than commercial
rockets
the emissions are going to come from
launches of
small satellite systems that that's you
know gps systems and various
communication systems that would be
where the bulk of the emissions from
rockets come from but our concern is if
that increases
and that may be likely to happen
luke piguet ceo of clear space says
we're just at the beginning of what
could be a booming space industry
bronson and mosque they're just kind of
scratching the surface of what space
tourism could be if you look at it the
space industry is a little like the
beginning of the aviation to be able to
send astronauts into orbit without
spacesuits is a huge step forward but i
think it's a real concern
uh in the space industry to make sure
that the operation is safe
reliable and sustainable
you